We watch, we listen.
and we remember.
The past is already written
The ink is dry
They have no idea, what's going to happen.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! So surprise surprise
HBO looks like it dropped its first teaser
for game of thrones season six way unexpected
so let's break it down so it sounds like the
Bloodraven is talking to Bran talking to him
about what happened in the past versus what
happened in the future because were going
to be talking about Bloodraven Bran stuff
just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
through season five on the show number and
set out season five but I just did a video
on the Bloodraven explaining how they recast
max Von Sydow out so that's his voice that
your hearing your you're also a hearing Bran's
voice he says they have no idea what's coming
so obviously he's talking about the war for
the darts of my the White Walker Army: the
Bloodraven says the past is already written
just expect to get some more Circe -type flashbacks
the fun thing though is that there are number
of different ways to accomplish that without
getting into too much book stuff I'll say
the weirwoods are tied to the greenseer's
powers the Bloodraven was the last greenseer
till bran came along the other big group that
shares this powers are the children of the
forest so I'm really hoping we get to see
more of them in season six but because there's
no actual footage from season six and this
teaser would just have to speculate that there
has been a lot of news from the set yet were
probably going to get a tower of joy flashback
we might get other flashbacks that's really
the only one that I'm counting on and no idea
that's going to confirm R + L = J or not it
is going to be freaking awesome you the way
now most of what this teaser focuses on his
stuff that's happening in west roast they
have cast a number of younger actors to play
existing characters on the show some of them
who are currently dead though I think they're
doing is it going to do all the flashbacks
that George RR Martin wrote in to dance with
dragons so if you want to read what the Bloodraven
is talking about George RR Martin actually
wrote those scenes and dance with dragons
so that is the book to reread if you want
to learn more brand stuff the big thing I
feel like it's going to be missing with that
are is cold hands not expecting any kind of
cold hands to show up on the TV show think
of him the way you would think of ladies stone
hard like that there might be characters with
shades of cold hands but I'm not expecting
the actual cold hands character let me know
in the comments though what you guys think
about this teaser and is and is so awesome
that they are not doing that site viral teaser
stuff that they did last year there was so
buggy that that did not work at all I think
the last time that they didn't teaser like
this like a teaser with no actual footage
for the next season was during season three
like they released it in the winter and the
next spring they released actual footage so
maybe they decided based on the reaction from
last year's teasers just to go back to the
old system like everybody is very comfortable
with like the teaser then you get the actual
trailers with big footage during the spring
what they might do is because the final series
the HBO's airing is gonna priest the game
of thrones they might drop the actual trailer
during a final broadcast for those that are
asking to it sounds like game of thrones season
six is going to premiere either late in April
maybe early May depending on whether there
is a break between the vinyl finale in the
game of thrones season six premiere but either
way let me know what you guys think about
this teaser I know there's large on snow and
it I've already done a Jon Snow teaser video
they released the images, messing with our
heads a little thought links that in the description
if you want to learn more about the Bloodraven
and his history in west roast all put a link
for that to this is one of the best early
holiday present sever I'm so happy and I totally
was not expecting it almost fell out of my
chair congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Michael Masco you and a $20 Amazon
gift card please private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info injured him just because this is such
a big deal on a reboot the giveaway extra
fast I mean I'm still doing a game of thrones
bonus video on Sunday but all you have to
do to enter the giveaway is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it was be
another 20 dollar Amazon gift card so what
I'm to do is a Q&A video for this on Sunday
so leave all your questions in the comments
so much awesome stuff happening right now
in case you haven't seen it I did a Batman
v Superman trailer video last night you can
click here to watch that and you can click
here to learn all about the Bloodraven in
a song of ice and fire. Thank you so much
for watching, everybody let's high five and
I'll see you guys tonight!